there was a tension in the room to be
sure when the final vote happened there
was a cheer that went up supporters of
this rule making backing Tom wheeler and
the two other Democrats have voted in
favor of it one of those people in the
room taking part in all this Steve
Wozniak of course we know him is one of
the cofounders of Apple someone who
understands the internet and these
issues very well and I wanted to find
out he dragged Steve over here to get
his immediate reaction first of all you
made the decision to come all the way
here to the FCC to witnesses why did you
come here I follow my heart I've only
done this sort of thing twice before the
other time was in 2010 to the FCC
meeting regarding net neutrality I
believe in the internet was so beautiful
when it first came even when it was
dial-up even went almost nobody had seen
it it was such an open and free
expression for him and then over time it
started getting closer and closer to
getting clamped down decisions were
being made by the ISPs the gatekeepers
you might call it and do we trust them
and we trust them to make decisions no
we need some kind of supervision of
their bad behavior are they likely to
make deals and accept bribes to show us
stuff everyone knows except a little
money and you give somebody preference
on their channels that's a bribe so
you're confident that the rulemaking
adopted today will in fact ensure an
open and free internet well I think
that's gonna pick me it's a big step
positive step I think that the other
side is also for open and free Internet
in terms of net neutrality the decision
today goes a lot further than net
neutrality title 2 regulation means
oversight of bad behavior not meddling
not controlling things not making
decisions but looking for bad behavior
and there could be a lot of things that
are illegal that are unconstitutional
behind the scenes in one of these big
ISPs and I don't think people trust them
that much but to me more than anything
else this is a victory for the people
the consumers the average joe's against
the big people that the suppliers who
have all the power and the wealth and
make the decisions for them and they
feel hopeless and helpless and here 4
million of us you know signed petitions
I see it as a sin and it's an indication
that the people can sometimes win we've
had a lot of defeats over the years but
once in a while we get a win let me ask
you about some of the criticisms we
heard from the Republican Commission get
your take on one of them is that this is
going to stifle investment that you
might not like the Internet service
providers but they are spending the
money to create these pipes in the first
place that's gonna dry up Tom wheeler
himself pointed out - an article in
today's Wall Street Journal which I've
read this morning that said that we
really don't think it's gonna matter and
make any change no I don't think this is
running their business I think all it is
is basically having some oversight of
bad behavior when they do bad things for
the people and the customers and what
about the notion that this is a solution
to a problem that doesn't yet exist that
you people can't really document the
notion that throttling and
discrimination is happening right now on
the web there's a lot of living to that
but there is a fear that could exist and
there are maybe things in the background
we don't even know about maybe that's
been going on inside those companies
because they haven't got enough
oversight we don't even know about it
as far as net neutrality goes everyone
agrees we need net neutrality this is
the right thing to do their bills by
Republicans in Congress of course after
fighting and fighting it all they could
for years and trying to overturn it they
now say oh it's the right thing to do
just to guarantee you at least that part
of this this decision this order all
right let me just ask you finally if you
were trying to start a company today the
apple of the future well today's
decision make that easier for the
entrepreneurs of tomorrow to make that
happen I don't think any different yes
it would yes today it would in the early
days the whole industry was growing the
starting from nothing and everybody had
a room to scramble to get in after a
while it condenses down to a few big
players the big 800-pound gorillas and
they do everything they can to stifle
and not let the little guys have a
chance together
and the innovators from the outside so I
think it improves it but slightly and
only in restricted places I don't think
it you know I'm hoping that it gets into
things like um broadband being able to
be declared a necessity should be
brought to everyone there's no there's
no big ISP that's gonna bring broadband
to my house I live a short little Segway
riding down the hill when I go into town
I take a Segway down not even a car I'm
that close and I don't have broadband
I'm in I'm in Silicon Valley and I don't
have brought me because I have no choice
it's a monopoly basically everyone who
gets broadband it's an essential service
of life brought to you by one company
it's a monopoly and that pipe that's
what I grew up with knowing these were
the utilities the things that we needed
for life that kid came into our house
that we had no control over and we
didn't have choice